argentinian gauchos
came out to mark independence day on
friday
and to join farmers and other
agricultural workers in nationwide
protests against the government of
alberto fernandez
they're angry because of a recent
government decision to reduce beef
exports
and attempts to nationalize companies
linked to agribusiness
farmer barnaby powell says the
government is making a mistake
they always use farmers as as a conflict
and uh because they are
they they say we are big landowners
and oligarchs and and
and it's not true we we do what we can
as any farmer in the world
argentina's government is trying to
control the price of beef
that has increased over 70 percent in
the past year
leaving many argentinians unable to
afford their own homegrown meat
exports mainly to china are blamed
thousands of people took to the streets
to express their frustration
with the administration of alberto
fernandez right here
is the agricultural sector that plays a
crucial role
in argentina's economy people here are
convinced that the government's attempts
to increase
the presence of the state in the economy
will deepen the recession
and affect argentina's chances of
recovering from the pandemic
alberto casey is a cattle breeder in
buenos aires
he said the government should try to
increase production instead of hurting
farmers like him
this isn't the first time something like
this has happened it happened in 2006
it's all obstacles caps troubles linked
to beef production and especially
exports
it ended with slaughterhouses shutting
down people laid off
thousands abandoning beef production
markets lost
and a loss of 11 million heads of cattle
[Music]
but it's not just the agricultural
sector many in argentina are angry with
the government's handling of the
pandemic
they believe the government should have
purchased more vaccines
instead of relying on lockdowns
quarantine and travel restrictions
that have stranded thousands of people
abroad
president alberto fernandez says his
government is working to protect the
most vulnerable
do you think that i could be happy with
the restrictions nobody can
if we have courage and can unite to
understand that nobody will save himself
on his own
that aside from being free and equal we
need to be fraternal
and kind to one another argentina is in
the middle of an economic crisis
negotiating with foreign creditors to
prevent a default on its sovereign debt
and struggling with a pandemic but the
country is polarized on how to fight the
battle ahead
and while some support the government's
policies others believe
they will lead argentina to further
decline
teresa al jazeera buenos aires